58% des nouveaux arrivants ne parle pas
français
nous ce qu'on propose c'est de mettre en
place un certificat temporaire puis de
donner aux nouveaux arrivants trois ans
au suit des cours de français qui seront
gratuits et réussir un examen de
français cette mesure de la caq charge
et a demandé au gouvernement fédéral
d'accepter de créer une nouvelle
catégorie des migrantes normalement dès
que le québec accepte un immigrant
économique
la loi fédérale fait en sorte que sept
migrants obtient un statut permanent au
canada à l'exception du droit de vote
les migrants pas les mêmes droits que
tous les canadiens la proposition de la
cac pourrait la retirer ses droits et
leur imposer un statut temporaire qui
pourrait durer jusqu'à trois ans donc le
fédéral devrait accepter qu'il y ait
deux classes des migrants au canada ceux
des autres provinces et ceux qui
arrivent au québec qui auraient moins de
droits et qu'ils devraient attendre plus
longtemps pour devenir citoyen servier à
changer les lois fédérales et
provinciales
ils entendent québec canada sur
l'immigration bref de longues
négociations à prévoir avec ottawa
et qu'est ce qui arrive si l'immigrant
qui est installée au québec
échouer aux tests de français a personne
qui aurait échoué son test de français
mais cette personne va se retrouver dans
une situation illégale
quentin immigrante illégale c'est au
fédéral qui revient la tâche de
l'expulser du pays avec françois legault
s'il immigrants installés au québec
depuis trois ans ne fait plus la sphère
québec voit lt le problème dans la force
du fédéral
[Musique]